Transcriber: Kadhim AL-Farttoosi
المدقّق: rana heloun
هل رأيت أجمل من هذا الحذاء في حياتكِ؟
هذا هدية عيد الميلاد.
يا أبي، أريد أن ألبس هذا الحذاء،
وأذهبُ به إلى الحارة،
لكي أريه لأولاد الحارة
أجمل هدية عيد ميلاد أخذتها في حياتي.
من أبونا (دوماجي)، كوني كنت أذهب
أصليّ كل يوم أحد على الصلاة.
أعطاني أحلى هدية.
لا أستطيع أن أنسى،
الطبيب الرومي لما جاء يُحَكِّمُ أمي،
وقال لها:
“ألبسوا الصبي شيئاً في قدمه“.
ظلتْ هذه الكلمة ترن في أُذني طوال الوقت.
نمتُ ليلتها وأنا أحتضن الحذاء بين يدي،
لم أصدق أنّي لأول مرة في حياتي،
سوف ألبس حذاءً!
أبو يوسف، غدٌ العيدُ
كيف سوف نطعمُ الأولاد في البيتِ،
وليس عندنا ولا حتى لقمةُ العدس؟
قولي لي إنتِ يا أم يوسف.
إذا ما العمل؟ كنتُ بوجع رِجْلِ
وأنتهيت بوجع رجليْن!
قولي لي ماذا أعمل؟
أبو يوسف...
نبيعُ الحذاء،
وبحقه نشتري الأكل للأولاد للعيد.
لا يا أمي، أرجوكِ، لا تبيعي الحذاء،
مستعدٌ أن أصومَ السنة كلها
فقط لكي ألبسهُ أول يوم العيد.
لا تأخذيه يا أمي، إِتركِيه لي يا أمي.
أخذتني على ساحة كنيسة المهد
ركبنا السيارة
أجلستْني في حضنها،
كي لا تدفع عني أجرة راكب.
توجهنا إلى القدس.
كم هناك من البشر
كم هناك من الناس،
كم هناك من بني آدم.
عبرنا من حارة إلى حارة،
ومن شارع إلى شارع.
لقيت حالي أمام دكان شخص، أخذَ الحذاء مني،
وأعطاني بدله حذاء مرقعاً.
هل تعرفي يا ستي؟
لا أريدُ أن أعيّد،
لم يعجبني الحذاء.
لكن في اليوم التالي صحيتُ في فناء البيت
على رائحة اللحم،
التي اشتريناها بحق الحذاء الذي لم ألبسهُ.
هذا جبرا، جبرا إبراهيم جبرا
الفلسطيني،
الكاتب، من بيت لحم
عاش بين جامع عمر وبين ساحة كنيسة المهد
المعاناة تعطينا دوافع للحياة،
تخلقُ عندنا محفزاتٍ من أجلِ التغيّير.
من فيكم عمره لم يحضر مسرح في حياته؟
أنا أول مسرحية أحضرها، كان عمري ثمان سنوات
كنت شبلًا في الكشافة، والكشافة أثرّت علينا
وقف الممثل راضي شحادة من مؤسسي المسرح
وكان يعلي صوته ويعمل حركات وإشارات
وأنا لست فاهم،
كنت ولداً صغيراً،
لكني أستطعت أن أتخيل ما الذي يريد إيصالهُ،
ماذا يريد أن يقولهُ للعالم؟
ذهبتُ إلى البيت وأنا متأثر به
وظللتُ أفكر، كم أثرّ فيَّ هذا المسرح؟
عندما كان عمري ١٦ سنة،
عشنا في ظروف صعبة جداُ،
حُرمنا من التعليم، أُغلقتِ الجامعات،
مجردُ التفكير بالخروج من البيت في سنة 1987
كي نشتري ربطة خبزٍ، كنا نفكرُ مئة مرة.
حتى هديةُ عيدِ الميلادِ
التي كنتُ أريدٌ شرائها لأختي
ذهبتُ إلى بيت لحم أبحثُ عن الدكاكين،
وجدتُ بيت لحم في عيد الميلاد حزينة.
الحزن مخيم على المدينة أكثر من فرح الميلاد
فصرت أفكر، كيف يمكنني أن أعبّرَ عن ذاتي؟
كيف يمكنني أن أعبّرَ عن هويتي؟
كيف يمكنني أن أعبّرَ عن قضية شعبي؟
فرأيتُ أنّ المسرح، هو صوتي.
لأن المسرح...
هو الأداة التي نعبّر بها عن هويتنا
وهوية مجتمعنا.
وبدأت علاقتي مع المسرح
وصرت أفكرُ وأقولُ
كيف يمكننا أن نطرقَ أبواب الناس،
ونصل إلى أماكنهم؟
ولا ننتظر الجمهور فقط كي يأتي لقاعة المسرح
ففكرنا إن المسرح المجتمعي مهم جداً
لأننا كشعب، نعيشُ في ظروف صعبةٍ جداً
لدينا الكثير من القضايا المجتمعية
التي من حقنا أن نتحدث عنها
ومن حقنا أن نسلط الضوء
على القضايا المجتمعية
التي يتعرضُ لها أطفالنا ونساءنا وشبابنا
ما هو المسرح المجتمعي؟
المسرح المجتمعي
عندما أنا أعالجُ قضية مجتمعية
من خلال الدراما والمسرح
ومن أجل أن انشئ مسرحاً،
يجب أن يكون عندي الكاتب الذي يكتب الفكرة
ويجب أن يكون عندي المُخرِج
الذي يترجم أفكار الكاتب
ويجب أن يكون عندنا الممثل الذي سوف يؤدي
ويجب أن تكونوا حضراتكم موجودون،
لكي نطرح هذه القضايا المجتمعية معكم
ليس فقط من أجل أن نلاقي حلولاً،
لكن من أجل أن نفكر مع بعض كيف نلاقي الحلول
المسرحُ لا يأتي بالحلول
المسرح المجتمعي يسلط الضوء على قضية
معينة ومن ثم نفكرُ مع بعض بالحلول
المسرح المجتمعي له أشكال مختلفة، ممكن
أن نقدم مسرح المضطهدين، أو مسرح المنبر
حيث أنا أعرضُ المشكلة وأضعك أنتَ كعنصر
مشارك ومتفاعل معي.
نكسر الجدار الرابع
ممكن أيضاً أن نقدم مسرح الشارع
حيث أنا أنقل فكري ومعاناتي
والقضية التي أريد تقديمها
أنزل بها إلى الشارع
أو من الممكن أن أقدم “ستريت ثييتر“،
مسرح الشارع
أنزل إلى الشارع في وسط الناس
بينهم ، بين كل الفئات التيأنا أريدها
وأتحدث عن القضايا المجتمعية
التي هم بحاجة إلى سماعها
كلنا بحاجة في حياتنا،
أن نلاقي أحداً يسمعنا، يعبّر عن قضايانا
يعبّر عن تحدياتنا ويتحدث ايضاً عن نجاحاتنا
مسرح الشارع وظيفتهُ أن يصل إلى
الأماكن النائية
وفلسطين جميلة، فلسطين بقراها، فلسطين
بمخيّماتها، فلسطين بمدنها
في المسرح المجتمعي نصل لكل هذه المناطق
البعيدة
حيثُ الناس أحيانا
لا توجد عندهم الإمكانيات
كي يصلوا هم إلى المسرح
في يوم من الأيام كنت أقدم مسرحية
مع المزارعين
نتحدث عن قضايا مختلفة، لأنكم إذا سألتموني
ما هو المسرح المجتمعي؟
وما هي القضايا التي نحن نتحدث عنها؟
نتحدث عن البيئة والصحة والجندر،
والنوع الإجتماعي
نتحدث عن التربية والتعليم وحقوق الطفل
ونتحدث عن قضايا المزارعين
فلما وصلنا عند المزارعين، لقيته جالساً
عند شجرة الزيتون ومسترخٍ
أقول له كيف كان الموسم هذه السنة؟
يقول لي الموسم هذه السنة “ماسية”
وعكس السنة الماسية ماذا تكون؟
“شلاتونة“، يعني ماسية عندما يكون
هناك زيتون كثير
وشلاتونة لما بيكون الموسم قليل.
رجعنا عندهم لكي نأخذ تغذية
راجعة من العروض التي قدمناها
فقال لي [المزارع]: هل تذكر
عندما حضرنا مسرحيتكم؟
قلتَ لنا وقتها عن ذبابة الزيتون،
التي تقضي على 500 حبة زيتون
ومن خلال العرض المسرحي عندما قدمتوا
وقلتوا لنا أن نُحْضرَ قنينة بلاستيكية
نثقبها ثقبين ونضع فيها خميرة
والذبابة تنجذب للخميرة
وتنزل لداخل القنينة وتعلق
وقتها نحافظ على 500 حبة زيتون
أنا أستطعت أن أقوم بقياس،
أنه عندما دخلنا المجتمعات...
المجتمعات المحلية والمزارعين
كنا قادرين على أن نصنعَ تغييراً
(تصفيق)
ليس سهلاً أن نصنع تغييراً
ولن نلاحظ التغيير الآن،
يجب أن يكون عندنا إيمان
ويجب أن يكون عندنا إرادة
نحن نضيء شمعة
ونكمّل الطريق
مثلما نضيء على الممثل،
الذي يخرجُ ويقدم هذه الرسالة
ومن خلال رسالته التي يريد تقديمها،
يريد أن يفتح طاقات عند الناس
كم هو صعب عندما نطرح قضية مجتمعية
ونلاقي أن البعض لا يتقبل الفكرة
لأننا نخاف، نخاف أن نفتح جِرارُنا المغلقة
صحيح؟
بجدّ، نجلس بينا وبين نفسنا ونقول،
من يريد أن يسمعني؟
من يريد أن يتحدث عن همّي؟ من يريد
أن يتحدث عن القضايا التي أريدُ عيشها؟
حياتنا بالتأكيد فيها واقع سياسي صعب
ولدينا واقع إقتصادي صعب،
لدينا واقع تعليمي صعب
ولدينا واقع قضائي صعب،
ولدينا...
ظروف كثير لا تتركنا
كي نعيش كيفما تعيش كل الشعوب
التي من المفترض أنها تعيش بكرامة في وطنها.
لهذا السبب أنا أقول
أن المسرح والمنصة
تعطينا مساحة كي نرفع صوتنا
محمد منير قال: عليّ صوتك بالغناء
غسان كنفاني بقلمه
كتب وعبّر عن هذه القضية الرائعة
وناجي العلي بريشته رسم
وأنتم أيضاً قادرين على التغيير،
من خلال موقعكم
سواءًا كنت أنتَ طالباً،
عاملاً، مزارعةً، قاضيةً، شرطيةً
ربةَ منزل
كلنا قادرين على التغيير
تسألوني، هل مطلوب منكم أن تكونوا ممثلين؟
أنا أقول: كلنا نستطيع فحياتنا،
أن نسرد ونحكي عن تجاربنا
أهم شيء هو أن نؤمن أن صوتنا
عندما يصل، نحن نستطيع ان نصنعَ تغييراً
شكراً لكم، يعطيكم العافية.
(تصفيق)